we can't get enough of frozen it gave us
two of the most beloved Disney
Princesses of all time while Elsa may be
in the spotlight Anna is actually pretty
interesting now let's dive into the
secret history of Anna from frozen Anna
from frozen is one of the most beloved
Disney Princesses of all time
she and her sister Elsa are so popular
they became their own franchise her
sweet strong and optimistic personality
make her an awesome role model fans all
over the world can't get enough of this
Scandinavian sweetheart and neither can
we
we love Anna and wanted to take a closer
look at her fascinating secret history
there's a lot to her both behind and in
front of the camera before we sink our
teeth into the juicy secrets of this
character let's take a look at the
secret history that created her tens of
time and careful consideration was put
into the development of Anna let's see
just how deep Disney delve to bring this
joyful princess to life three voices
Anna is voiced by the incredibly
talented Kristen Bell she's won a Golden
Globe for Best Actress for her role on
the TV show at the good place with a
powerhouse like that behind the mic Anna
was sure to be a hit the creators of the
film loved Kristen so much that they
infused a ton of her features and
personality into her character animators
confirms that they took quite a lot of
inspiration for honest features and
expressions from Kristen they also
wanted to give her some of the actors
awkward but bubbly personality they even
included some of Kristen's quirks
Anna has an adorable catchphrase over
and over in the movie she asks her
signature question how many times have
you heard on a pause and ask wait what
did you know that Disney riders added
those words to the script because the
actor who voices Anna Kristen Bell
provides the voice for grownup Anna she
apparently has a habit of asking the
same question in real life the writing
team was so taken by Kristen and her
quirk that they decided to weave it into
the movie other characters get in on the
cute homage to Kristoff Olaf and even
Elsa get in on the action this adorable
line infuses more of the star's perky
personality into the film we love this
adorable phrase and we're so glad the
creators weaved it into the script
Kristen Val isn't the only voice to
massively influence what we hear when we
think of Anna did you know that one
point in the film
people provided the voice of this
red-haired princess during the epic song
do you want to build a snowman it took a
total of three talented actors to bring
on it to life Katie Lopez provides the
voice for the youngest version of Anna
in the song katie is a talents legacy
both of her parents are accomplished
actors her mom Kristen anderson-lopez
lent her voice to films like Coco and
Ralph breaks the Internet
her dad Robert Lopez is an award-winning
writer he helped create Avenue Q and the
Book of Mormon that's a pretty
impressive family of talented creators
Agatha Lehmann provides the voice of
adolescent Anna in the song she's also
got a lot of talents in her family her
mom has written for wreckit-ralph a
wrinkle in time and much more she's also
the director of frozen having a woman
direct an animated feature was a Disney
first Kristen Bell provides the voice
for teenaged Anna and continues to voice
her for the rest of the film she helps
us transition to the very grown-up
princess who unites her kingdom and
saves her sister from exile it's no
surprise it took so much talent to voice
this dynamic character the choices in
voice acting blend perfectly to create
the illusion of watching Anna grow up
the film frozen is based on a classic
tale called The Snow Queen the book was
written by Dutch author Hans Christian
Andersen the creators of the film
decided to honor the author of the
original story with their own character
creations some of the characters names
are a playful nod to the beloved writer
Hans Kristoff Anna and Sven all have the
privilege of being part of this sweet
nod their names together sound a little
bit like the authors when you say them
quickly we can't help but find that
detail adorable it did awesome way to
honor the man who laid the groundwork
for the story to develop frozen isn't
the only Disney story he created he also
wrote The Little Mermaid his stories
lend themselves perfectly to the Disney
formula of storytelling his versions are
a bit more grown-up but the building
blocks are there the relationship
between Elsa and Anna is a foundation of
the entire story the bonds between these
sisters is what makes the entire movie
work understanding that special bond
between sisters was essential for the
filmmakers the creators held a sister
summit in order to better understand a
sisterhood and
help create onna our perfect princess
didn't just happen by accident
the production team called together
women from all over the studio who had
grown up with sisters they spent hours
discussing their experiences and what
sisterhood meant to them I like the open
gates we are never closing them again
the creator's took all of this
information and wove it into one of the
best character relationships in Disney
history if all of this behind the scenes
info wasn't enough reason for you to
fall head over heels in love with onna
this next fact is sure to win you over
onna literally saved the film without
her there wouldn't even be a frozen for
us to freak out about when Disney
creators first tried to adapt the Ice
Queen to an animated feature they
struggled the main character was just
too problematic for them to turn into a
family-friendly princess at first Elsa
was an icy villain with nothing to make
the audience love her it seemed like a
concept that was doomed
but the creator's refused to let it go
there were several versions of the story
written and scrapped before they hit on
the secret sauce that makes the movie
work once they introduced the character
of Anna everything fell into place the
dynamic relationship between the sisters
made the story much more relatable and
softens the character of Elsa
it wasn't until Anna's upbeat
personality was added to the mix that
frozen was born and the rest is Disney
history from the moment frozen was
conceived anna has played a huge part in
making the film a hit so much went into
making the optimistic princess we've
talked about all the secrets behind her
creation and developments but what about
Anna as a character
trust us she has plenty of hidden
history too let's start with a Disney
theory that spans four films and nearly
two decades of Disney history it's been
discussed all over the Internet's by
fans around the globe when the gates of
arendelle are open for Elsa's coronation
guests arrive from all over the world
this is a huge event for the royal
family dignitaries from other kingdoms
come to pay their respects to the late
king and queen but also to witness the
crowning of a new leader while Lana
sings for the first time in forever she
greets the incoming crowd in one frame
we see a famous couple who provide a
hint at a family secret Eugene and
Rapunzel can be seen entering the city
to attend the coronation cameos like
this are never simple or meaningless in
the Disney Universe
there is a reason rip on
shows up mm-hmm big summer blowout
Rapunzel and Ana are actually cousins
their families ruled two separates and
distant kingdoms but they're related
Rapunzel had been held captive for so
long that she never got to know her
cousins in arendelle as soon as she
heard about the passing of her aunt and
uncle she must have been devastated she
had to make an appearance at the
coronation to meet her long-lost family
and get to know her cousins Disney has
confirmed that when the king and queen
passed away at sea they had been on
their way to a wedding this fits the
exact timeline of when Rapunzel and
Eugene were tying the knot knowing that
her aunt and uncle lost their lives on
the way to her wedding must have been
tough for Princess Rapunzel a secret
cousin is pretty juicy stuff it's not
every day you find out you have a
relative you never knew about
Rapunzel isn't the only missing piece to
Ana's family history after her parents
left arendelle a whole new chapter in
the secret family history would be added
the death of the king and queen is a
major catalyst for the movie if they had
returned home the story would have met
it's happily ever after about ten
minutes in what if the king and queen
didn't die during the shipwreck this may
be the biggest secret in Ana's history
her parents ship was destroyed and they
were never heard from again
that much is true and they would
eventually die they actually survived
the shipwreck and found their way to a
jungle island they built themselves a
shelter and found ways to feed
themselves while on the islands the
Queen fell pregnant she and her husband
welcomed their handsome baby boy into
the world separated from their loving
daughters shortly after their bouncing
baby boy was born the king and queen
finally met their end they were killed
by the big cats that they shared their
jungle home with their son was spared
and was soon as opted his gorilla family
named him Tarzan they made sure the baby
was kept safe and thrived
Ana's secret little brother lives the
tie between frozen tangled and Tarzan is
epic secret family ties long-lost little
brothers and cousins reunited are about
as exciting as it gets this one event
ties in one more of the Disney Universe
in the Little Mermaid Ariel stores her
human artifacts in a sunken shipwreck
observant fans have noticed that the
king and queen of arendelle set sail in
a ship that looks exactly like the one
Ariel spends her time in that means that
at least for Disney film
are all tied together by honest parents
and their faithful trip may be the best
part of this four-way tie in is that
it's largely been confirmed directly by
Disney creators
during a reddit AMA fans asked where the
king and queen were headed on their
fateful trip writer and director
Jennifer Lee confirmed they were headed
to a wedding at the exact same time that
Rapunzel and Eugene were about to be
married co-director Chris buck further
clarifies that the king and queen didn't
die in a shipwreck
he told fans of the king and queen
survived lost at sea for weeks before
they landed on a lush jungle island
there they built themselves a home next
to a family of gorillas it's worth
noting that Chris has the inside scoop
on another Disney film he was also the
director of Tarzan if anyone was
qualified to confirm the link between
the two films it's him the rich
character development of frozen helped
make it the international sensation it
is today Disney creators knocked it out
of the park when they created Anna her
addition to the story made the entire
film possible without the masterfully
written relationship between her and
Elsa the story would be lacking its
heart Anna breathes the soul into frozen
it's her optimism and sheer
determination that brings her sister
back from the brink her hidden history
is a rich part of the story that we
think everyone should know we hope you
loved looking behind the curtain at what
makes honest such a dynamic character
what's your favorite thing about Anna is
there something about her you just can't
resist let us know in the comments below
what you love about this perky princess
we love sharing these disney secrets
with you and we hope you love learning
them we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]